hey guys it's Evan I'm hoping you can  help me with a dilemma I'm facing here  on one of my videos that are going to be  uploading soon I went to the captions  and this is what YouTube thinks I'm  saying and they think I'm saying hi  muffin comical I believe that hungry  entreprises our help now I'm actually  saying hi I'm Evan Carmichael and I  believe that hungry nurses are pal so I  want to know is Evan Carmichael that  hard to pronounce is it me I'm not  pronouncing it properly or is it YouTube  love you know what you guys think I want  to hear it in the comments is it my  problem or is it YouTube's falters to  the captions up ok let me know thank you  guys for tuning in and we'll see you  soon